Thermik, wie entsteht die Thermik?
Wir haben die Sonne, wie wir es schon besprochen haben, das ist der Motor des Wetters.
Die Sonne scheint auf der Erdoberfläche und erwärmt die badennahe Luftschicht.
Dementsprechend gibt es am Boden eine etwas erwärmere Luftschicht.
Das ist ganz wichtig für die Thermik zu verstehen.
Wenn wir am Fliegen sind oder die Thermik suchen, müssen wir uns immer fragen,
welche Luftmasse, respektive welcher Boden, erwärmt sich mehr als der andere.
Es geht immer um einen Temperaturunterschied.
Es muss nicht per se warm sein, im Winter können wir auch Thermik fliegen.
Wenn die Wälder z.B. schneefrei sind, erwärmen sich die mehr als ein schneebedeckter Wiesenhang.
Dementsprechend ist die Thermik über dem Wald zu finden.
Also der Temperaturunterschied ist immer ganz wichtig.
Das hat auch mit dem Albedo-Effekt zu tun, weil die Untergründe sich stärker erwärmen als die anderen.
Es gibt z.B. einen trockenen Acker, der abgernt ist.
Er erwärmt sich mehr als eine grüne Wiese, die vielleicht sogar noch feucht ist.
Also muss man sich immer fragen, welche Oberfläche erwärmt sich mehr.
Und da gibt es auch die Grundregel, je reflektierender eine Oberfläche ist,
z.B. Schnee, die erwärmt sich praktisch mehr.
Oder eine schwarze Oberfläche oder eine dunkle Oberfläche erwärmt sich natürlich viel mehr,
weil sie viel mehr Wärme aufnimmt von diesen Sonnenstrahlen.
Was auch ganz wichtig ist zum Erwärmen, ist der Sonneneinfallswinkel.
Im Idealfall ist das so, dass die Sonnenstrahlen, die wir hier sehen,
im rechten Winkel auf eine Fläche treten.
Dementsprechend wird diese Fläche sehr viel stärker erwärmt,
als eine Fläche, die geneigt ist, wo die Sonnenstrahlen nur sehr flach eintreffen.
Denke z.B. wieder zum Polargebiet und zum tropischen Gebiet.
Das hat z.B. auch nur mit dem Einfallswinkel der Sonne zu tun.
Dementsprechend bildet sich am Boden eine warme Luftschicht, die eine Blattere bildet.
Und die warme Luftschicht, wenn sie genügend Temperaturunterschied hat,
und abgelöst wird durch einen kleinen Trigger,
löst sich diese ab und beginnt zu aufsteigen.
Da kann man sich das ein wenig vorstellen wie eine Lavalampe.
Diese Luftmasse bleibt geschlossen.
Das ist wieder eine Luftmasse.
Das ist eine Luftmasse mit einer einheitlichen Eigenschaft.
Sie ist wärmer als die Luftmasse rundherum.
Und sie steigt weg.
Also haben wir hier zwei Luftmassen.
Wir haben draussen die Atmosphäre, die eine gewisse Temperatur hat,
auf die wir auch noch kurz eingehen.
Und die warme Luftschicht, die aufsteigt.
Die Blattere, die aufsteigt.
Und die Thermik bildet.
Ihr könnt euch vielleicht auch einen Heissluftballon vorstellen.
Der steigt auch, weil er wärmer, warme Luft hat,
die weniger dicht ist.
Dementsprechend steigt der Heissluftballon.
Das Gleiche ist mit der Thermik,
mit dieser thermischen Blase, die aufsteigt.
Jetzt wieder, wir haben einen gewissen Luftdruck,
der herrscht auf unsere Atmosphäre.
Wir haben im unteren Bereich einen höheren Luftdruck,
wie in den oberen Schichten.
Jetzt kommen wir wieder zurück zum Luftdruck.
Jetzt seht ihr, wir fangen auch Sachen an zu verknüpfen.
Dementsprechend, wenn so ein Luftballon steigt,
kennt vielleicht manche vom Tauchen.
Oder mit so einem Wetterballon sieht man das sehr eindrücklich.
Wenn er tief unten ist,
dann hat er ein sehr kleines Volumen von dem Gas, das dort drin ist.
Wenn er aufsteigt, wo der Luftdruck hier sinkt,
dann kann sich der Gas immer mehr ausdehnen.
Und dementsprechend nimmt er Volumen zu,
von dem Luftpaket, das steigt.
Und danach kommen wir zu der Abkühlung.
Wenn der Ballon steigt,
dann gibt es eine Dekompression,
der Druck sinkt von dem Luftpaket, der steigt.
Der dehnt sich aus, der Druck sinkt.
Und wenn in einer Luftmasse oder in einem Gas allgemein der Druck sinkt,
dann nimmt die Temperatur ab.
Das seht ihr zum Beispiel sehr eindrücklich,
wenn ihr bei einer Pressluftpistole zum Beispiel,
wenn ihr Luft rausblaset, dann ist die eiskalt.
Das hat eigentlich nur damit zu tun,
dass die komprimierte Luft aus dem Kompressor
sich sehr schnell ausdehnt und daran abkühlt.
Also eine Luftmasse, die sich ausdehnt, kühlt sich ab.
Dementsprechend nimmt man das Gegenteil.
Wenn eine Luftmasse komprimiert wird,
dann erwärmt sie sich.
Das sieht man in der Praxis zum Beispiel auch,
wenn man einen Reifen aufbläst.
Wenn man einen Druckreifen aufbläst,
dann wird er ganz warm irgendwann.
Und das ist, wenn man dort ganz viel Luft komprimiert.
Behaltet immer dieses Bild im Kopf.
Es ist ganz wichtig für verschiedene meteorologische Phänomene,
jetzt auch in der Thermik.
Wenn man sich die Zahlen anschaut,
kann man sich vorstellen,
dass der Boden mit 20 Grad weg ist.
Das sind jetzt einfach die ungefähren Zahlen.
Und dann steigt es auf
und die Temperatur nimmt immer mehr ab in der Höhe.
Genau.
Das hat mit Dekompression zu tun
und mit dem Aufsteigen dieser Luftmasse.
Letztlich, wenn wir uns das einfach vorstellen,
haben wir in der Atmosphäre
einen gewissen Temperaturgradient.
Im Idealfall wird es in der Höhe immer kälter.
Die Luftmasse liegt hier in der Nacht zum Beispiel.
Flieht in der Nacht die Luftmasse hier.
Die ist am Boden unten ein bisschen wärmer
als in der Höhe.
Im Land Everest ist es sehr viel kälter
als am Meer unten zum Beispiel,
um es sich bildlich zu vorstellen.
Und da ist der Temperaturgradient,
das ist wieder ein Verlauf,
ein Gradient,
ein Temperaturgradient von dieser Luftmasse,
der einfach hier liegt.
Und jetzt kommt am Morgen die Sonne auf,
der Motor des Wetters beginnt zu wirken,
beginnt die Flächen am Boden aufzuheizen
und die Thermik steigt weg
und kühlt sich ab.
Und durch den Abkühlungsprozess,
hat die Thermik meistens,
erreicht sie irgendwo einen Bereich,
wo sie gleich kalt ist,
wie die Umgebungsluft.
Jetzt hier in diesem Fall ist die Thermik top,
an dem Punkt erreicht,
wo die Luftmasse minus zwei Grad hat.
Und auch die Umgebungsluft,
wo ihr dort auf dort sitzt,
ist ja irgendwo an einem gewissen Punkt
genau gleich kalt,
wie das Paket, das steigt.
Dementsprechend,
der Heissluftballon hat nicht mehr mehr Wärmevorsprung
und er wird nicht mehr weiter steigen.
Die Thermik hört an einem gewissen Punkt auf.
Genau,
da hat mit der Temperatur-Zustandskurve,
sagt man dem auch,
die Temperatur-Zustandskurve beschreibt
eigentlich nur die Atmosphäre,
also die Schichtung der Luftmasse,
wie sie da liegt.
Die Abkühlung,
die jetzt hier stattfindet,
die beschreibt man auch
als adiabatische Vorgänge
oder als adiabatische Abkühlung.
Und da gibt es zwei davon,
da werde ich nachher dann gleich drauf eingehen.
Und man kann sich vorstellen,
wie die Luftmasse aussenrum
einen gewissen Zustand hat.
Da einfach noch etwas anders dargestellt,
um sich zu vorstellen,
dass da zwei verschiedene Luftmassen sind,
das ist ganz wichtig.
Da finden nur sehr wenige Durchmischungsprozesse statt.
Und vor allem jetzt so,
wie man es in der Theorieprüfung lernen möchte,
ist das das Relevanteste.
Es gibt dann noch einen Meteor-Advance-Kurs,
wo wir sehr viel genauer auf Thermiktheorie eingehen.
Dort gibt es noch andere Effekte,
die relevant sind,
die jetzt aber für den Basistheorie-Kurs
sehr viel zu weit wirken.
Genau,
jetzt sehen wir die Temperaturabnahme,
die der Luftpaket teurer macht.
Und da kommt noch ein zweiter Faktor dazu,
der für uns als Piloten wirklich sehr wichtig ist.
Und da geht es um die Luftfeuchtigkeit.
Wir haben ja in einem Luftpaket,
auch jetzt hier drinnen in diesem Raum,
haben wir einen gewissen Anteil Wasserdampf.
Also wir haben nicht nur Sauerstoff und Stickstoff,
sondern wir haben auch einen gewissen Wasserdampfanteil
in unserem Luftpaket.
Luftfeuchtigkeit,
die ist verschieden feucht.
Je nachdem,
was für eine Luftmasse ist.
Da kann man sich vorstellen,
mit diesen blauen Pünktchen,
da haben wir den Wasserdampf in diesem Gas.
Und wenn jetzt der Luftpaket aufsteigt
und sich abkühlt,
dann hat der Wasserdampf immer weniger Platz,
kann man sich so vorstellen.
Und es gibt irgendwann den Wechsel,
wo die Luftmasse nicht mehr mehr
Feuchtigkeit aufnehmen kann.
Und dann beginnt sich der gasförmige Wasserdampf,
der Aggregatszustand wechseln in Flüssig.
Flüssig ist relativ,
weil wir sehen da meistens als Wolken.
Also jeder Nebel und jede Wolke ist eigentlich nichts anderes
wie Wasser in der Luft.
Und so ganz, ganz mikroskopisch kleine Wassertröpfchen.
Das muss ja nicht gerade Regen sein,
sondern es sind wirklich ganz, ganz kleine Tröpfchen,
die man so wahrnehmend sieht,
für uns vom Auge her mehr wie ein Gas aus.
Aber es sind eigentlich Wassertröpfchen in der Luft.
Und dann reden wir vom Kondensationsstoff.
Der Kondensationsniveau,
wo die Luftmasse anfängt zu kondensieren,
der Wasserdampf, der dort drin ist.
Ein Wort, den wir auch immer wieder mal hören,
ist die relative Luftfeuchtigkeit,
die dann zunimmt.
Und bei 100 Prozent ist natürlich der Punkt erreicht,
wo die Luftmasse nicht mehr mehr Feuchtigkeit aufnehmen kann.
Genau.
Dann, wenn der Kondensationsprozess einsetzt,
wenn der Wasserdampf zu Wasser wird,
also wenn es wirklich zu kleinen Wassertröpfchen wird,
dann nachher passiert physikalisch ein Phänomen,
dass, wenn es von gasförmig in flüssig übergeht,
das Wärme freigesetzt wird.
Da wird ein bisschen Wärme freigesetzt.
Und natürlich auch, wenn es von flüssig
noch in festen Zustand würde wechseln.
Das sind die drei Aggregatszustände.
Danach wird ein bisschen Wärme freigesetzt,
ein bisschen Energie freigesetzt in diesem Prozess.
Das andere ist natürlich umgekehrt.
Wenn wir einen Aggregatszustand wechseln haben
von fest in flüssig oder von flüssig in gasförmig,
dann wird die Wärme entsorgen.
Ein wichtiger Punkt bei diesem Kondensationsprozess
ist die Milchbüchleinrechnung,
die wir uns hier gerade anschauen.
Und das ist wichtig für euch,
um zu verstehen, was hier ungefähr passiert.
Wenn die Luftmasse steigt, kühlt sie sich ab.
Solange sie trocken an die Apathe steigt,
also ohne dass ein Kondensationsprozess stattfindet,
ist das ganz einfach.
Das ist nur 1 Grad pro 100 Meter.
Also wenn sie steigt,
kühlt sie sich 1 Grad pro 100 Meter ab
in dieser Thermikblase.
Das ist ganz einfach.
Die Zahl könnt ihr euch merken.
Beim flüssig-adiabatischen Prozess
beginnt die Milchbüchleinrechnung.
Und zwar haben wir die 1 Grad pro 100 Meter,
wo sie sich abkühlt.
Aber dem entgegen schafft der Kondensationsprozess,
der immer ein bisschen Energie freisetzt
in Form von Wärme.
Und dann wird hier natürlich
von diesem Grad pro 100 Meter
ein gewisser Betrag abgesorgen,
was am Schluss so über den Daumen
0,65 Grad pro 100 Meter ausmacht.
Der Wert, wie ihr hier seht,
ist nicht immer genau gleich.
Das hat damit zu tun,
dass eine warme Luftmasse
mehr Feuchtigkeit aufnehmen kann
als eine kalte.
In einer warmen Luftmasse haben wir dementsprechend
mehr Feuchtigkeit, die anfängt zu kondensieren,
als in einer kälteren Luftmasse,
zum Beispiel in Polarregionen.
Dementsprechend ist der Wert
ein bisschen am variieren.
Für euch ist aber wichtig zu wissen,
dass der einfach kleiner ist als 1 Grad.
Hier ist die Milchbüchleinrechnung
der feucht-adiabatischen Abkühlung.
Diese zwei Zahlen könnt ihr euch merken.
Und jetzt schauen wir,
was das in der Praxis zu bedeuten hat.
Jetzt sehen wir die Luftmasse,
die hier unten steigt.
In diesem Fall eine troche-adiabatische Abkühlung
mit einem 1 Grad pro 100 Meter.
An einem gewissen Punkt
erreicht die Luftmasse, die steigt,
das Kondensationsniveau.
Der Kondensationsprozess steigt
und beginnt.
Dementsprechend kühlt sich die Luftmasse
nur, jetzt in diesem Fall,
0,65 Grad pro 100 Meter ab.
Das ist der feucht-adiabatische Prozess.
Der findet so lange statt,
bis, wir hatten es vorhin,
der Luftpaket die gleiche Temperatur
hat wie die Umgebungsluft.
Das sind die zwei
adiabatischen Abkühlungsprozesse,
die ihr wissen müsst.
Dann haben wir hier vielleicht ein Bild
aus der Praxis,
aus der Flugpraxis.
Man sieht die Landschaft.
Ihr müsst euch die Frage stellen, wo steigt
die Luftmasse am besten weg?
Oder wo erwärmt sich viel wichtiger
der Boden am meisten?
Das ist rechtwinklige Sonneneinstrahlung.
Vielleicht ein Boden, der sich etwas mehr erwärmt
als der Boden aussen herum.
In diesem Fall erwärmen sich sicher
die Wiesenflächen etwas mehr
wie ein Wald.
Im Südhang steigt irgendwann die Thermik weg.
Sie steigt auf, steigt auf, steigt auf
und bildet irgendwann
wunderschöne Kummelausfülle,
die die Thermik anzeigen.
Wenn wir jetzt natürlich
noch Wind dazu haben,
wenn wir uns vorstellen, dass ein Ballon
aufsteigt, dann driftet der natürlich
im Wind hinein, mit dem Wind.
Und dementsprechend ist es
ein Puzzlespiel, wenn man hierher kommt
beim Streckenfliegen, wo fliege ich an?
Man muss auch immer zusammensetzen,
wo löst sich die Thermik ab
und wo bildet es ein schönes Wühlchen.
Was auch noch ein wichtiger Punkt ist,
die Thermik, die thermische Luftmasse,
die steigt, die muss nicht immer
ein Kummelausfüllchen bilden.
Also das kann auch sein, dass der
Temperaturvorsprung der Thermik,
ich denke an den Ballon, erreicht ist,
also dass er sich ausgleichen hat,
bevor so ein Kondensationsprozess
stattfindet. Danach hat es
genau gleich, da hinten hat es vielleicht
genau gleich eine Thermik, aber die hat
aufgehört zu steigen, bevor es
kondensiert ist. Dementsprechend
sprechen wir von Blau-Thermik.
Das ist so der Begriff, den ihr merken könnt.
Blau-Thermik ist eigentlich nichts anderes
als Thermik, die nie kondensiert ist.
Genau. Ein Begriff für die Thermik,
den man auch immer wieder mal hört,
ist der Begriff von Le-Thermik.
Wir hatten es vorhin, Lauf
und Le. Le, die
windabgewandte Seite des Berges.
Wenn wir uns hier einen Wind vorstellen,
ist das die windabgewandte Seite
dieser Berge. Vielleicht haben wir
eine Sonneneinstrahlung, die
genau diese Flächen,
Einstrahlungswinkel der Sonne,
mehr erwärmt, wie auf der anderen Seite.
Dementsprechend steigt die Thermik da am besten weg.
Dementsprechend sprechen wir von Le-Thermik.
Also Thermik, die am Ende da ist,
auf der windabgewandten Seite.
Das passiert natürlich meistens dann,
wenn wir zum Beispiel einen Nordwind
haben, jetzt in der Alpe.
Weil die Südseite der Berge
in der Alpe, die erwärmt sich auch immer am besten.
Also Südhänge sind am besten.
Wenn wir jetzt einen Nordwind oder eine Beise
dazu haben zum Beispiel,
dann kommt der Wind von Norden.
Dementsprechend ist die Le-Thermik
sehr ausgeprägt.
Le-Thermik hat meistens die Eigenschaft,
dass sie turbulenter ist.
Also Le-Wirbel, mechanische Turbulenzen.
Seht ihr, jetzt fangen wir immer mehr an zu verknüpfen.
Wir haben hier mechanische Turbulenzen,
die natürlich die Thermik verhacken.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie ein Häcksler,
der je nach Windstärke die Thermik
turbulenter macht.
Aber meistens ist die Le-Thermik auch
ein bisschen stärker.
Weil die Luftpakete, die da im Le,
im windgeschützten Bereich liegen,
die konnten sich länger aufheizen.
Dementsprechend sind sie sehr viel wärmer,
wie eine Lufthermik zum Beispiel.
Also wenn man jetzt
die andere Windrichtung hätte,
dann wird der Luftpaket
vom Wind immer wieder wegtransportiert.
Und dementsprechend kann sich
die Luftmasse im Luf
nicht so lange aufheizen,
wie eine Le-Thermik.
Das ist jetzt aber etwas,
das schon eher vorgeschritten ist,
aber gut zu wissen.
Wichtig ist, dass ihr wisst,
was eine Le-Thermik ist.
Jetzt kommen wir davon,
dass von der Temperaturzustandskurve,
das ist ganz wichtig,
von der Luftmasse, die steigt,
und wir reden von der Luftmasse,
die einfach da liegt,
die sich in der Nacht gebildet hat,
einfach den Zustand der ganzen Luftmasse,
die über der Schweiz liegt in diesem Moment.
Und ab diesem Punkt
reden wir wirklich nur noch von der Luftmasse,
die da liegt, nicht mehr von der Thermik.
Die Luftmasse kann verschiedene Geschichten sein.
Im Idealfall oder im Normalfall
ist die Warmluftmasse unten
und sie wird immer kälter,
desto höher das geht.
Zum Beispiel bei einer labilen Luftschichtung.
Ihr könnt euch vorstellen,
wenn der Heissluftballon steigt,
dann kann der Temperaturvorsprung
sehr viel länger halten,
weil es oben immer kälter wird,
als wenn wir jetzt das Gegenteil hätten,
die sogenannte Invasion.
Da gibt es mit speziellen Wetterlagen,
mit Hochdruckeinfluss zum Beispiel,
gibt es Inversionen,
umgekehrt,
dass wir oftmals unten kalt haben
und auf den Berggipfeln oben haben wir sehr warm.
Das gibt es ja manchmal im Winter,
wenn es starke Invasionen hat.
In Zürich am See ist es kalt,
man sitzt im Nebel unten
und auf den Gipfeln oben, beim Skifahren
ist das schönste, wärmste Wetter,
wo man fast im Tisch sitzen kann.
Das ist eine sogenannte Invasion.
Und jetzt könnt ihr euch vorstellen,
wenn die Thermik dort hineinsteigt in eine Invasion,
wo es oftmals wärmer wird in der Höhe,
dann haben wir keinen Temperaturvorsprung mehr.
Danach hört eigentlich die Luftmasse gleich aufsteigen.
Und dementsprechend reden wir von
einer sehr stabilen Schichtung.
Das ist eine stabile Schichtung,
ohne zu wenig Thermik zu erwarten.
Sehr ruhige Luftmassen auch.
Da gibt es richtig milchige Verhältnisse.
Wunderschön für Heikenfleisch und so,
aber nicht so schön zum Thermikfliegen.
Unten gibt es den Mittelbereich,
eine sogenannte Isothermie,
sagt man dem.
Das ist, wenn der Temperaturzustand
in der Höhe genau gleich bleibt.
Wenn wir im Tal unten 6 Grad haben
und auf dem Berg oben 6 Grad haben,
dann ist eine sogenannte Isothermie
eine gleichbleibende Luftschichtung.
Genau.
Der Temperaturzustand aber in der Atmosphäre
ist definitiv so, dass es unten warm ist
und oben immer kälter wird.
Jetzt gibt es hier ein paar Prüfungsfragen
zu dieser Invasion
oder labilen Luftschichtung etc.,
wo ihr hier einen Temperaturgradient
aufgeschrieben seht in Textform
auf 500 Meter ist 15 Grad,
auf 800 Meter ist 14 Grad etc.
Das wird hier also aufgelistet.
Und jetzt werdet ihr hier natürlich oft gefragt,
wo ist denn eine Bodeninvasion?
Dann müsst ihr überlegen,
ich schaue hier unten auf 500 Meter,
und eine Inversion, aha,
ist eine umgekehrte Luftschichtung.
Das heisst, es wird wärmer in der Höhe.
Dann müsst ihr hier nur noch die Zahlen herauslesen.
Jetzt zum Beispiel 1 ist 15 Grad
und auf 800 Meter ist 16 Grad.
Das wird wärmer, das ist eine Inversion.
Das Gleiche bei der Höheninvasion,
findet das Gleiche statt,
einfach in höheren Höhen.
Oder eine Isothermie,
jetzt zum Beispiel 4 hier, wo wir 8 Grad haben,
auf beiden Höhen,
das ist eine gleichbleibende Luftschichtung.
Das ist also ein Prüfungsbeispiel.
Dann kommen wir jetzt zum nächsten Kapitel,
das wichtig ist.
Da machen wir das Kapitel
«Wulchennamen» auf, «Wulchenformen»,
«Wulchenbilder» und was das für uns bedeutet.
Bei den Vulchen ist es so,
wie in dieser Darstellung,
gibt es viele latinische Namen
und das ist manchmal sehr kompliziert,
um sich das zu merken und was das bedeutet.
Das ist ein richtiges Türenland.
Jetzt versuchen wir das mal zu ordnen
und wie das zustande kommt.
Für die Vulchennamen
mache ich für meinen Kopf
einen 2x3 Raster
und dann gibt es noch einen Kasten
für spezielle Vulchen,
die nicht in diesen Raster gehören,
aber 2x3 Raster könnt ihr euch vorstellen.
Dann gibt es grundlegend zwei Arten
von Vulchengattungen.
Das eine ist eine Cumulus-Vulche,
eine Cumulierung,
ein Cumulus-Punkt,
eine Ansammlung von etwas,
das sind so Haufen-Vulchen,
Haufen-Vulchen heissen die,
alles, was eine Cumulus-Vulchen-Form hat.
Dann gibt es den Stratus,
das ist eine Schicht-Vulche.
Alles, was zum Beispiel Nebel ist,
ist eine richtige Schicht-Vulche.
Alles, was so schön in den Horizontalen
ausdehnte Vulchenfelder sind.
Die zwei Vulchengattungen unterscheiden sich
vor allem daran, dass Cumulus-Vulchen
sich vor allem bilden,
wenn sehr starke
vertikale Luftmassenwechsel
stattfinden, also wenn ein Thermikaufstieg
zum Beispiel oder wenn auch in hohen
Luftschichten eine Luftschicht zum Steigen
gemacht wird.
Dann gibt es die Vulchenformen
von Cumulus-Vulchen.
Bei Stratus ist das Gegenteil.
Das spricht eigentlich eher dafür,
dass es stabile Luftmassen ist,
dass da wenig vertikale Bewegung drin ist,
sondern dass da eher eine horizontale Vulche ist,
die sich so ein bisschen setzt.
Einfach auch ein bisschen fürs Verständnis,
was passiert da mit diesen zwei Vulchenformen.
Auf der Seite haben wir
Stockwerke,
die verschiedenen Höhen der Vulchen.
Da haben wir Ciro-Vulchen.
Eis-Kristall.
Das ist eine sehr hohe Höhe.
Die bestehen eigentlich nur noch aus Eis-Kristall.
Dann haben wir das Alto-Stockwerk.
Das ist eine hohe Vulchenschicht.
Das ist so zwischen 4 und 7 Kilometer.
Und dann haben wir den Grund,
wo eigentlich nur noch die Grund-Vulchengattungen sind.
Da seht ihr jetzt gleich,
wo eigentlich kein Zusatznamen mehr dazugehört.
Die Höhen
sind immer relativ.
Da variiert man ein bisschen.
Das sind vielleicht mal 3 Kilometer
auf 8 Kilometer. Das ist nicht fix.
Das ist eine sehr definierte Höhe.
Aber wichtig ist,
die alten Vulchen sind wirklich so über
2000-3000 Meter deutlich drüber.
Und Ciro-Vulchen sind wirklich 8 Kilometer drüber.
Also sehr, sehr hohe Vulchen.
Und jetzt können wir eigentlich nur noch
die Namen anfangen einfügeln
von diesen verschiedenen Vulchen.
Da seht ihr, da kann man es nur noch zusammensetzen.
Da gibt es ein Ciro-Crumulus.
Das setzt sich aus diesen zwei Namen zusammen.
Dann gibt es ein Ciro-Stratus.
Das ist eine milchige Suppe,
die sehr, sehr hoch oben ist.
Das nennt man meistens, wenn es so ein Halo gibt.
Also so einen runden Regenbogen
in sehr hoher Höhe.
Das ist der Ciro-Stratus.
Das ist eine Schichtvulche wieder.
Dann haben wir den Altocumulus
und den Altostratus.
Unten haben wir Cumulus und den Stratus.
Das sind dann nur noch die Grundformen.
Das ist noch wichtig.
Cumulus und Altocumulus unterscheiden sich
vor allem dadurch, dass der Cumulus
durch Sonneneinstrahlung entsteht.
Das ist wirklich der thermische Aufwind,
wie wir es gerade besprochen haben.
Wenn sich eine kältere Luftschicht
unten hineinschiebt,
dann beginnt die warme Luftschicht zu wegsteigen
und bildet so kleine Cumulus-Vulchen.
Alles auf der linken Seite
deutet auf eine labile Luftschichtung ein.
Die Luft ist sehr steigfreudig.
Da haben wir wieder die Labile, Stabile.
Alles rechts reden wir eher
von einer stabilen Luftschichtung.
Also die Luft ist nicht sehr steigfreudig.
Und wir haben tendenziell
eher Invasionen anzutreffen
bei Stratus-Vulchen.
Das sind die zwei Vulchengattungen.
Die sich dann zusammensetzen
und aus diesen beiden nehmen.
Es ist ganz einfach,
wie sich das einteilen lässt in diesem Raster.
Danach haben wir natürlich noch ein paar Spezial-Vulchen.
Wir haben schon noch ein paar Spezial-Fälle dazu.
Die eine Vulche im Stratus-Bereich
ist der sogenannte Nimbus-Stratus.
Nimbus steht für Regen.
Dementsprechende Schicht-Vulchen,
die richtig ausregnen.
Das haben wir oft bei einer Warmfront
oder in einem Tiefdruckgebiet,
wo es einfach am Schiffen ist,
wo es einfach nur regnet.
Das ist in der Regel ein Nimbus-Stratus.
Also Niederschlag.
Dann haben wir noch Zirus-Vulchen,
also ohne Zusatz.
Zirus-Vulchen sind Federn-Vulchen.
Das sind sehr hohe, klassische Federn-Vulchen.
Das ist für uns,
für das Fliegen, auch nicht so relevant.
Dann haben wir die Lenticularis,
eine ganz spannende Vulche,
auf die wir jetzt eingehen.
Und für uns eine der wichtigsten Vulchen
ist die CB oder Cumulonimbus.
Das ist die ausprägte
Gewitter-Vulche.
Diese fliegt und tonnet und regnet
und ist für uns wirklich am gefährlichsten.
Sie dehnt sich wirklich
vom unteren Stockwerk
bis in die Tropospausen nach oben aus.
Dazu kommen wir gleich noch.
Und logischerweise gibt es noch
sehr viele Spezial-Vulchen
und detaillierte Namen,
wo man sich fachsimpeln kann.
Aber für euch, für das normale Fliegen,
ist wirklich die Anvorrelevanz der Rest.
Da müssen wir auch nicht tiefer drauf eingehen.
Zum Thema Vulchen
gibt es auch noch den Bewölkungsgrad,
den man immer wieder im Wetterbericht liest
oder im Segelflug
im Wetterbericht etc.
Da sprechen wir immer von Achtel.
Dementsprechend 8 Achtel Bewölkung
ist eine geschlossene Vulchendecke.
Wir sehen keinen blauen Himmel,
es ist alles zu.
0 Achtel, logischerweise keine Vulchen,
vielleicht nur Blau-Thermik,
wenn es überhaupt Thermik hat.
Könnte es ja dort auch Blau-Thermik haben,
haben wir wieder verknüpft.
2 Achtel sind bedeckt,
2 Achtel des Himmels sind bedeckt
und die anderen 6 Achtel
sind blau und frei.
Und natürlich 4 Achtel sind halb bewölkt.
4 Achtel ist eigentlich eine schöne Bewölkung
für uns zum Thermikfliegen.
Etwas zwischen 3 und 4 Achtel,
weil wir schöne Cumulus-Vulchen haben
und hier haben wir noch genug blauen Himmel,
damit die Sonne den Boden abnimmt,
damit wir schönes Wetter haben,
damit sich die Thermik entwickelt.
Das ist der Bewölkungsgrad.
Eine sehr spannende Vulchenform,
Lenticularis,
sicher die, die die meisten Piloten kennen
oder die man schnell einmal hat.
Die Lenticularis braucht eigentlich
2 oder 3 Inhaltsstoffe.
Das eine ist ein Gebirge,
das andere ist ein sehr starker Wind.
Lenticularis-Vulchen deuten immer
auf einen sehr, sehr starken Wind ein.
Und wir brauchen natürlich
ein bisschen Luftwichtigkeit,
damit es auch anfängt zu kondensieren.
Das passiert meistens entweder
direkt über den Berggipfel
oder auf der Lehseite des Gebirges.
Das sind so Toren,
die die Luft in eine Wellenbewegung bringen
und dementsprechend bildet sich immer
oben an dieser Wellenbewegung
die Luftmasse steigkondensiert,
bildet sich so eine Wolke,
hinten sinkt sie wieder ab,
sie hört auf zu kondensieren
und dann gibt es so Wellenwulchen.
Vielleicht für uns wichtig zum Fliegen zu wissen,
das ist ein sehr starker Wind,
aber dadurch, dass das Gebirge
immer am gleichen Ort stehen bleibt
und die Wellen dementsprechend
immer am gleichen Ort stehen bleiben,
ist das für uns wichtig.
Nur weil eine Wolke stehen bleibt,
heisst das nicht, dass es keinen Wind hat.
Logischerweise.
Aber ihr kennt diese Wolkenformen
sicher sehr eindrücklich
und für alle Gleitschirmflieger
immer so ein Alarmzeichen,
wenn ihr lentikulare Wolken seht.
Dann haben wir ein ganz wichtiges Thema,
das ist der Wind.
Das ist ein ganz wichtiges Thema,
Dann haben wir ein ganz wichtiges Thema
für Gleitschirmflieger,
das sind die Gewitter.
Bei den Gewitter ist es so,
dass ein Gewitter nichts anderes ist
als ein Cumuluswölkchen,
das gewachsen ist und weiter wächst.
Das ist ein ganz grosses,
böses Thermikwölkchen.
Das macht es für uns eben auch
genauso gefährlich,
denn wir wollen ja Thermik fliegen.
Wir fliegen ja genau an den Tagen,
an denen es unter Umständen
immer weiter fliegt.
Wir müssen vorsichtig werden,
wenn die Gewitterwulchen zu gross werden.
Am Morgen sieht man die ersten Cumuluswölkchen,
wir gehen fliegen,
am 11. ist alles schön,
wunderbare Flugbedingungen.
Danach werden die Gewitterwölkchen
oder Cumuluswölkchen schon etwas grösser.
Die entstehen natürlich mit der Sonne.
Wir brauchen immer den Motor der Sonne.
Der Motor fängt langsam an zu zünden.
Er ist so wie ein Motor,
der langsam in Gang kommt.
Wir müssen langsam vorsichtig werden,
wenn die Gewitterwulchen sich
anfangen zusammenschliessen.
Wir haben hier kleine Wölkchen
und auf einmal schliessen sich
zwei Wölkchen zusammen.
Aber da reden wir schon von grossen Flächen,
das ist nicht ein kleines Puffi-Wölkchen,
sondern von grossen Wölkchen,
die ein paar Kilometer Ausdehnung haben.
Sobald sich die Wölkenbasis
anfängt zusammenschliessen,
müssen wir vorsichtig werden.
Vor allem, wenn die Wölkenbasis
auch langsam dunkel wird.
Man kann sich vorstellen,
dass durch die Wassertröpfchen
und irgendwann, wenn die Wölke hoch wird,
die Sonnenstrahlen fast nicht mehr durchkommen.
Das ist der Punkt, wo langsam
die Wölke dunkel anfangen zu erscheinen,
wo unter der Basis auch dunkel ist.
Und das ist der Punkt,
wo man langsam anfangen muss aufzupassen
und was natürlich auch viel mit Erfahrung zu tun hat.
Wie lange fliege ich noch?
Wie lange bleibe ich unter dieser Wölke?
Ist das schon eine grosse Wölke oder nicht?
Das ist wirklich ein Bereich,
wo man als vorgeschriebener Pilot
sehr viel Vorsicht braucht.
Und auch so eine Grundregel ist,
wenn es auf einmal überall anfängt zu steigen,
jetzt sind wir morgen am Fliegen,
es ist immer schwierig gewesen,
die Thermik zu finden,
die lokalen Aufwinde.
Und dann auf einmal fängt es überall an zu steigen.
Überall im Tal raus kann ich fliegen
und es steigt und oben da ist eine Wölke gross.
Da müsst ihr wirklich anfangen vorsichtig zu werden.
Weil dann fängt die Tür
von diesem Gewitter langsam an zu laufen.
Und irgendwann schliessen sich immer mehr
und sie werden immer höher.
Und es braucht eigentlich nicht mal mehr Kraft
von der Sonne,
weil der Motor fängt sofort an zu drehen.
Weil warme Luft steigt auf,
kühlt sich ab, keilt wieder runter.
Da wir kalte Luft haben,
steigt die Warmluft nur schneller auf
und dann gibt es so wie eine Kettenreaktion
und ein Turbo, der anfängt zu zünden.
Und die Wölke wächst nicht immer,
aber oft bis an die Tropospause.
Und dann gibt es diese schönen
Ambrosformen der Wölke.
Das ist, wenn die Gewitterwölke oben ansteigt,
kann man sich vorstellen,
wie eine Plexiglasscheibe,
die drüber liegt, wo die Wölke hinwachsen
und dann kann sie nur noch in die Breite
und bildet den Ambros.
Und in dieser Phase, in der der Gewitter ausgeprägt ist,
gibt es sehr viel Reibung in der Luftmasse,
die sinkt und steigt.
Und dementsprechend gibt es manchmal Blitz
und es gibt vor allem auch Niederschläge.
Ähm, dazu zum Gewitter.
Und etwas, wo ich euch wirklich
ins Herz legen möchte, ist,
jeder hat Angst vor dem Gewitter,
wenn er drunter ist.
Also die Steigwerte sind extrem,
da müsst ihr wirklich vorsichtig sein.
Ähm, aber noch viel vorsichtiger
ist auch die Gefahr
von dem Outflow von so einem Gewitter.
Die Luftmasse, die steigt und sich dann
extrem abkühlt auf diesen 13'000
Meter oben,
die keilt irgendwann runter
und das ist wie ein Kübel Wasser, das man ausleert.
Und dementsprechend
leert die kalte Luft
aus und die ist ja schwer
und kalt, also die geht am Boden an.
Und die kann es richtig ausleeren
und die geht dann in die Täler rein
und an die Landeplätze runter
und die kann auch sehr viel weiter weg vom Gewitter
noch sehr starke Turbulenzen verursachen.
Also das ist dann nicht nur die Gefahr
unter dem Gewitter direkt,
sondern es ist wirklich eine riesige Gefahr
auch neben dem Gewitter.
Weil die Kaltluftausstösse gehen wirklich unten rein
und das macht die Landung extrem turbulent
und gefährlich
und ist sehr, sehr unangenehm.
Und die Kaltluft oder Ausstösse kann dann
unter Umständen auch wieder das nächste Gewitter
verringern, wo dann wieder warme Luftmassen
die jetzt zum Beispiel im Talboden unten liegen
kommt die kalte Luftmasse runter
die warmsteigt wie das Wetter und gibt dann wieder
die nächste Turbulenz
und vielleicht sogar das Gewitter.
Also da müsst ihr wirklich vorsichtig sein
von diesen Kaltluftausstössen des Gewitters.
Es ist fast gefährlicher als der Aufwind.
Also der Aufwind ist auch gefährlich logischerweise
aber die Kaltluftausstösse sind die,
die leider viele Piloten immer wieder unterschätzen.
Wenn ihr euch das anschaut, sieht das so aus.
Wenn ihr immer natürlich Niederschläge
unter einer Wolke seht, dann ist es sowieso
die letzte,
ist sowieso Ultima Ratio, um zu landen
oder möglichst weit weg zu fliegen
und dann so schnell wie möglich zu landen.
Aber wenn es natürlich so aussieht, ist es dann gar nicht mehr gut
zu fliegen. Das ist ein richtiger Outflow.
Da seht ihr richtig, wie der Kübel Wasser
ausgeleert wird und wie es massiv
Kaltluft unten rauslässt.
Und das verursacht wirklich viel Wind.
Dann auch wieder zum Radar, wie wir es schon einmal gesagt haben.
Es ist wichtig, schaut euch das Radar an,
was passiert.
Schaut euch die Wolke unten an.
Wenn es Wolken sind, seht ihr nicht, wie hoch sie oben sind.
Aber ihr seht vielleicht eine andere Wolke
50 Kilometer weg. Und wenn das schon ein riesiger Turm ist,
dann wisst ihr, dass vielleicht
die Wolke überall auch nicht viel kleiner ist.
Dann beim Radar ist es ganz wichtig,
schaut euch das Radar an, das ist eine gute Sache.
Aber schaut euch an, habt eure Augen
offen draussen. Reines Radarbild ist
immer etwas verzögert und da ist
manchmal auch nicht gleich das, was
überall ist. Das kann sehr schnell entstehen und
das ist vielleicht manchmal noch gar nicht wirklich sichtbar auf dem Radar.
Also habt eure Augen immer auch
offen und schaut euch an, was überall passiert.
Und wie es aussieht.
Und wenn es eine mittelgrosse Wolke ist,
vielleicht auch noch ein kleiner Tipp.
Wenn es jetzt noch nicht gerade eine Gewitter ist,
aber einfach eine Cumulus-Wolke, die ihr findet,
ist die jetzt schon am saugen, ist es noch gut oder nicht,
dann fliegt doch einfach am Rand der Wolke.
Dann seid ihr schnell immer wieder weg von
dieser Aufwindzone, wo ihr vielleicht Mühe habt,
um wieder runter zu kommen. Also dann lieber
am Rand der Wolke fliegen. Aber selbstverständlich
bei Gewitter wirklich vorsichtig sein.
Das hat sehr viel mit Know-how zu tun.
Und das ist manchmal auch ein bisschen Spiel mit dem Feuer,
wenn es wirklich um Gewitter geht.
Genau. Dann kommen wir
zu einem weiteren wichtigen Kapitel.
Zum
Talwindsystem.
Das ist ein ganz wichtiges Phänomen, das übrigens in allen
Gebirgen stattfindet. Auch bei uns
in den Alpen. Und zwar
haben wir wieder, jetzt seht ihr,
da fangen wir immer wieder an zusammensetzen,
wir haben die Sonneneinstrahlung,
die beim Gebirge
sehr viel mehr Wärme produzieren kann.
Oder sich besser erwärmen kann,
als im Flachland.
Und dementsprechend wird die Erwärmung
im alpinen Raum
einen
tieferen Luftdruck im
Tagesverlauf. Und wir haben es
gehabt, die Luftmasse will den Druck immer ausgleichen.
Wir haben einen höheren Druck
im Flachland
und einen tieferen Druck
im Gebirge. Und dementsprechend
gibt es eine Ausgleichsströmung
im Tagesverlauf.
Achtung, das ist nicht zu verwechseln mit einem
Hoch- und Tiefdruckgebiet auf einer Isobarenkarte.
Da sehen wir, das wird natürlich nie
so dargestellt in einer Isobarenkarte. Aber wir haben
einen höheren Druck und einen tieferen Druck.
Aber genau das gleiche Wetterphänomen
mit dem Druckausgleich, mit dem
Windsystem, der zustande kommt.
Und dementsprechend gibt es die Ausgleichsströmung
im Tagesverlauf.
Die ist meistens am stärksten,
ab 11 Uhr fängt sie an,
die Spitze erreicht sie
um 3 Uhr am Nachmittag.
Und von der Jahreszeit her ist es so,
dass im Frühling, sobald
der inneralpine Raum
langsam schneefrei wird,
dann fängt er langsam an.
Dann geht er so bis in den Herbst hinein.
Wird im Sommer immer schwächer
gegen Herbst. Aber die Spitzezeit ist
sicher so im Juni hinein, sage ich mal.
Wenn die thermische Aktivität auch am
stärksten ist. Also es braucht immer
thermische Aktivität, die das auslöst.
Wenn wir natürlich bedeckten Himmel
haben oder Invasionen haben,
die keine Thermik auslösen, dann gibt es
auch nicht wirklich ein Talwindsystem.
Genau.
Dementsprechend in der Nacht
gibt es Gegenteile.
Wenn ein Bergwind einsetzt,
dann setzt es meistens am Abend
so ab 6 Uhr ein.
Dann haben wir oftmals einen höheren Druck
im Alpenraum, weil die Berge sich schneller
abkühlen als das Flachland.
Das Flachland erkennt ihr vielleicht.
Wenn ihr am See sitzt, ist es sehr viel länger
noch warm als im Gebirge, wenn die Sonne
langsam weggeht. Dementsprechend haben wir
auch dann wieder einen Druckunterschied,
wo wir einen höheren Druck im Flachland
haben, äh einen tieferen Druck im Flachland
haben, Entschuldigung. Dementsprechend
eine Ausgleichsströmung, die so ab 6 Uhr
langsam einsetzt.
Und es gibt das Phänomen
der Umkehrthermik,
dass wenn die Kaltluft in den Bergen abfliesst,
dass manchmal die etwas wärmere Luft
im Tal wegsteigt.
Da ist so eine Umkehrthermik,
eine Konvergenz, die sich dann bildet,
die meistens in der Talmitte stattfindet.
Und manchmal
so ein spezieller Ort, zum Beispiel ein Interlaken,
da gibt es einen wirklich schönen Aufwind,
wo man manchmal bis in die Nacht
fliegen könnte, wenn man es dürfen würde.
Da gibt es spezielle Wetterphänomene.
Aber das ist der Bergwind, der einsetzt.
Was übrigens auch für den Startplatz
ein Problem ist, wenn man innerhalb des Fliegers
hohe Berge hat, dann ist da manchmal
wie ein Schalter, der einsetzt am Abend,
der Bergwind, und dann kommen wir manchmal kaum mehr
vom Startplatz weg. Das ist etwas, das man manchmal
auch noch einberechnen muss,
dass der Bergwind auch noch einsetzen kann.
Genau. Dann zum
Talwind, das ist ganz wichtig für euch zum Wissen.
Der Talwind kann wirklich ein Problem werden im Frühling,
weil er kann sehr, sehr stark werden.
Und da gibt es eine super Talwindkarte
beim SAV, die hat ein bisschen mit
Erfahrung zu tun. Haupttäler
könnt ihr euch vorstellen, so wie eine Wurzel
von einem Baum, die sich zusammenschliesst.
Je weiter im Haupttal man ist,
also wo diese Wurzel dick ist,
desto mehr Talwind haben wir,
wo richtig Alpenhauptkamm reingesagen wird.
Also das Rintel zum Beispiel, das Rhonetal
und so weiter, das sind alles Täler,
die sehr starken Talwind verursachen können.
Da kann man manchmal 50-60 km
der Stunde Talwind geben.
Wir sind am Thermikfliegen im Wallis.
Wenn ihr jetzt im Juni im Wallis fliegen geht,
dann habt ihr vielleicht super schöne thermische
Temperaturen.
Oben im Talwind, der ist ja nur im Tal
drinnen, der ist wirklich im Talboden drinnen,
bei 500 Metern über dem Grund, je nachdem.
Ihr könnt hier oben thermisch fliegen und dann
müsst ihr ins Tal landen und auf das Mal
habt ihr sehr viel Wind. Und da muss man
wirklich in den Haupttälern im Frühling
gut überlegen, wann man gerade landen muss
oder man muss vielleicht sogar
entweder gerade top landen.
Das ist etwas, wo ihr wirklich aufpassen müsst,
wenn ihr in den Alpenhaupttälern fliegt.
Es gibt dann auch noch so spezielle Phänomene
wie in Maloia oben.
Das sind so Talwinde, die überschwappen,
über den Pass ausschwappen und dann
hinten runterfallen und auch sehr turbulente
Luftkämpfe verursachen.
Das sind sehr lokale Phänomene,
wo man sich aber informieren muss,
wenn man zum Beispiel im Grimsel oben fliegt
oder in Maloia. Da sollte man
wirklich vorsichtig sein.
Also wenn ihr dort fliegt, informiert euch
über die Talwindsysteme. Wichtig für eure
Theorieprüfung ist, ihr müsst wissen,
wann die Talwinde zustande kommen
und um welche Zeiten das sind.
Das ist eigentlich das, was ihr euch da abfragen wollt.
Und etwas, das man immer wieder einrechnen muss.
Genau. Dann kommen wir
zu einem weiteren Wetterphänomen,
das für Gleitschamflieger mega, mega wichtig ist.
Und zwar ist das der Föhn.
Ich sage immer, es gibt drei Hauptgefahren
für Flieger. Es ist Gewitter,
es ist der Föhn und es sind
wahrscheinlich so Talwinde.
Das ist noch so ein Kapitel. Weil bei allen
anderen Wetterphänomenen habt ihr am Startplatz
starken Wind. Wenn Westwind kommt,
dann habt ihr einen sehr vollen
Westwind am Startplatz und dann merkt ihr,
das ist vielleicht nicht so eine gute Idee, um zu starten,
wenn man mega Wind hat und ihr eh schon Mühe habt,
so mit Luft zu kommen. Föhn,
Gewitter und Talwind,
das sind eigentlich die einzigen Wetterphänomene,
wo auf der einen Seite das
Flugwetter extrem schnell umschlagen kann,
also es kann sehr schnell turbulent werden,
und auf der anderen Seite sind die
meistens auch am Landeplatz unten am stärksten.
Also es kann sein, dass ihr
im Talwind am Berg oben startet
und ruhige Bedingungen habt und im Tal unten
ist es am Krutten und hat wirklich mega viel
Wind. Bei Föhn ist das Phänomen
eben genau gleich. Da fühle ich
zum Föhn, wie kommt der Stand,
wie viel Windsystem,
wie wir es gehabt haben, einen Druckausgleich.
Wir brauchen einen Druckunterschied,
also wir brauchen zwei Zutaten für Föhn.
Wir brauchen einen Druckunterschied
und wir brauchen einen grossen Gebirgszug.
Sprich, Föhn
gibt es in allen Regionen der Welt.
Da gibt es sie im Himalaya, da gibt es sie in der Anden,
da gibt es sie in der Pyrenäen
und da gibt es sie bei uns in der Alpe.
Der Föhn hat immer wieder einen verschiedenen Namen,
da gibt es nicht wirklich einen Namen,
der rund um die Welt gleich heisst.
In der Alpe hat sich aber Föhn etabliert
und es gibt einen Nordföhn und einen
Südföhn, also der geht auf beide
Seiten natürlich hier und her.
Für uns jetzt auf der Alpen-Nordseite
ist natürlich der Südföhn der, der Probleme macht.
Jetzt in dem Fall haben wir links das Sein,
rechts haben wir das Deutsche Flachland
oder unsere Voralpen.
Wir haben einen höheren Druck auf der Alpen-Südseite
wie auf der Alpen-Nordseite.
Dementsprechend will
die Luftmasse den Druck
ausgleichen und strömt
über den Gebirgskamm aus.
Beim Föhn ist vielleicht noch wichtig,
dass je nach Situation
der Föhn richtig vom Flachland
angesagt wird. Man kann sich vorstellen,
wie ein Staubsauger, der da hinten Luft anzieht.
Und diese Luft
keilt richtig in die Täler hinein
und keilt je nach meteorologischen Bedingungen
wirklich bis in den Talboden hinein
und kann sehr sehr starke Wind verursachen
im Tal hinein. Da gibt es auch manchmal spezielle
Wetterlagen, wo am Startplatz nicht immer viel
Wind wäre, aber in einem Föhntal
hat es extrem starken Wind.
Das macht es natürlich für uns jetzt auf der Alpen-Nordseite
gefährlich, weil bei Föhnen
haben wir meistens viel Sonne,
schönes Wetter, blaue Himmel, alles ist schön,
es wäre eigentlich super schön zum Fliegen,
es würde auch immer mega anmachen.
Aber das macht es genauso gefährlich beim Föhn,
dass dieser genau in so einer schönen Wetterlage
wahrgenommen, zustande kommt.
Und zwar steigt die Luftmasse
in diesem Fall auf der Alpen-Südseite
auf, sie kondensiert,
wir haben es wieder, Luftmasse steigt auf,
sie kondensiert, bildet eine Wolke,
unter Umständen regnet es sogar aus
und sie geht über den Alpen
Hauptkamm aus, bildet eine sogenannte
Föhnmauer, das ist wirklich wie eine Mauer,
die dem Alpenhauptkamm nachgeht.
Sie keilt hinunter,
trocknet aus,
es löst die Wolken aus und der trocken
warme Wind keilt ins Flachland
hinein, in die Alpenteller hinein
und bildet natürlich sehr, sehr starke
Turbulenzen und Fallwind und Scherrwind
und auch die Leerotoren,
die unter Umständen auch die
Lenticularis-Wolken bilden können.
Wichtig ist, Föhn
muss nicht immer Regen verursachen
im Süden oder es muss nicht immer
Lenticularis verursachen.
Föhn kann auch manchmal trocken sein
und die Wolkenformen nicht zeigen.
Das ist jetzt einfach der klassische Föhn,
wie es wirklich meistens entsteht,
wenn es eine schöne Staubbewölkung gibt.
Also der Druckunterschied ist vor allem wichtig.
Auf der Isoparenkarte
sieht das ungefähr so aus,
wenn man sich die Ringe anschaut,
wenn man keine Gebirge hätte,
dann würden die hier einfach rund weiterlaufen
und einfach den Luftdruck
gleichmässig verteilen.
Jetzt haben wir aber den
Gebirgskamm, den Alpenhauptkamm
und man sieht auf der Smali
in der Isoparen so einen Knick
beim Alpenhauptkamm,
den sogenannten Föhnknie sagt man.
Also wenn ihr auf einer Isoparenkarte
über einem Gebirgszug so einen Knick seht,
ganz einen massiven Knick,
dann hat er meistens mit Föhn etwas zu tun,
dann müsst ihr anfangen vorsichtig zu werden.
Und wieder, wie wir es hatten,
dort wo die Isoparen näher zusammen sind,
haben wir viel Wind.
Was jetzt in diesem Fall
im Vorfeld von dieser Kaltfront
den Föhn bringt.
Das ist übrigens ein Wetterphänomen,
das oft bei uns in der Schweiz stattfindet,
bevor eine Kaltfront eintrifft.
Aber ganz wichtig, es muss nicht immer
im Vorfeld von einer Kaltfront sein,
es kann auch mal Föhn geben,
ohne dass eine Kaltfront kommt.
Aber so der Klassiker ist,
eine Kaltfront nähert sich von Westen her,
es bildet sich ein Föhnknie,
es gibt eine Föhnströmung
und irgendwann bricht die Front durch,
es gibt ein Föhn-Diagramm,
da gibt es verschiedene Anbieter,
da gibt es ein Föhn-Diagramm,
da gibt es auch vom SAV auf der Meteo-Seite,
wo wir ja Zugang haben,
wirklich ganz gute Darstellungen,
das ist jetzt von dem Meteozentralen Föhn-Diagramm,
wo wir in der Mitte 0 Hektopascal-Linie haben,
da reden wir immer vom Druckunterschied,
wenn wir jetzt eine Luftdruckstation haben,
einen Barometer im Tessin haben
und einen Barometer in Zürich haben zum Beispiel,
und man dort den Druckunterschied misst,
dann weiss man ja auch,
ob es eine Ausgleichsströmung auf der einen Seite
oder auf der anderen Seite geben könnte.
So als Faustregel, da seht ihr die gestrichelte Linie,
reden wir von 4 Hektopascal.
Wenn die
Kurve oben ausschlägt,
dann über die 4 Hektopascal
reden wir von Südföhnen,
unten reden wir von Nordföhnen,
zum Beispiel hier am Samstag und am Freitagnacht
reden wir eher von Nordföhnen.
Und das ist sehr unbeständiges Wetter jetzt auf dieser Prognose,
der Druck schlägt extrem hin und her
und das bedeutet eigentlich immer viel Wind,
viel Bewegung in der Luft
und eigentlich in der Regel kein gutes Flugwetter.
Jetzt ist auch wichtig für euch zu wissen,
dass ihr wirklich die Wetterberichte gut leset
und euch bewusst ist, dass der Föhn
manchmal bei 4 Hektopascal durchbricht.
Manchmal kann man auch
bei 8 Hektopascal noch fliegen,
das ist für niemanden zu empfehlen
und es hat wirklich sehr viel mit Erfahrung zu tun
und man muss auch das Gebiet sehr gut kennen.
Und da würde ich wirklich nicht empfehlen,
bei Föhnigen Bedingungen zu fliegen.
Man hört dann immer so,
ich bin ja noch mit 8 Hektopascal
in dem und dem Fluggebiet geflogen
und das war überhaupt kein Problem.
Der kann manchmal Türen brechen,
manchmal nicht Türen brechen.
Da hat er sehr viel damit zu tun,
welche Richtung der Föhn hat.
Der kann manchmal südwestig sein,
es kann manchmal südostigen Föhn sein.
Das hat mit den Temperaturschichtungen in der Luft zu tun.
Da würde es den Vortrag sprengen.
Über Föhn könnte man 2 Stunden reden
und philosophieren.
Wichtig ist auch, dass wenn eine Föhntendenz
rum ist, dass ihr euch wirklich gut überlegt,
ob ihr wirklich fliegen gehen wollt.
Und der Föhn hat da schon
einen Piloten erwischt.
Das kann wirklich sehr unterschiedlich sein.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Auch zu dieser Kurve.
Nur weil es bei 4 Hektopascal ist,
heisst das nicht, dass es keinen Föhn geben kann.
Darum ist es auch in der Meteopraxis,
die wir in einem anderen Kurs anschauen,
wirklich wichtig damit zu tun,
dass ihr Windmesswerte anschaut,
das Gebiet gut kennt,
die Druckkarten anschaut,
die prognostizierten Werte
mit der Realität abgleichen,
mit den wirklich gemessenen Werten an diesem Tag.
Das ist ja alles von einem Computermodell.
Da muss man es nicht alles so eintreffen.
Die können sich auch ein wenig vertun.
Das hat dann sehr viel mit Erfahrung zu tun.
Also seid mit Föhn vorsichtig.
Bei Föhn ist es so,
die Luftmasse will wie Wasser,
wie alle Gase,
den Weg des geringsten Widerstands gehen.
Dementsprechend sind Täler,
die von Süd nach Nord ausgerichtet sind,
wie jetzt zum Beispiel das Rintel,
sehr viel Föhn-anfälliger
als ein Tal, das quer geht.
Also die Luftmasse
wird von der Südseite
irgendwie auf die Alpen-Nahseite kommen,
jetzt im Fall des Südföhns.
Dementsprechend gibt es spezielle Föhngebiete,
wo man speziell vorsichtig sein muss.
Informiert euch hier bei den Clubs,
bei den Flugschulen, im Fluggebiet,
auf verschiedenen Websites,
wo man diese Informationen findet,
ob gewisse Gebiete Föhn-anfällig sind oder nicht.
Und seid wirklich konservativ,
wenn es sich um Föhngebiete handelt.
Da seht ihr so eine Karte,
findet ihr auch beim SRV, ist wirklich gut.
Diese Sache, um sich hier informieren zu können.
Hier haben wir noch die letzte Folie,
Föhnbilder, einfach,
dass ihr hier noch einmal visuell gesehen habt.
Wir haben die schönen Lenticularis-Wulchen
und wir haben eine Föhnmauer,
das ist dann wirklich eine so schöne Mauer,
die so wie eine Kralle bildet
und die Luftmasse, die hinten runter sinkt,
die abtröchnet.
Und da sieht man manchmal wirklich ganz deutlich
und klar, dass sich am Alpen-Hauptkamm
eine richtige Föhnmauer bildet.
Und wenn ihr so eine Wulche seht,
das ist nie eine gute Sache zum Fliegen
und wird immer turbulente Wind verursachen,
wenn wir von Föhn oder sonst auch
von starkem Wind reden.
Wichtig, wie gesagt, Föhn muss
nicht immer mit diesen Wulchenformen zusammenkommen.
Es kann auch blauer Himmel sein
und keine Wulchen haben und föhnen.
Das ist wichtig für euch zu wissen.
Jetzt habt ihr wirklich die drei Hauptgefahren
besprochen.
Wir haben den Theoriestoff abgedeckt,
weil es für die Theorieprüfung wichtig ist.
Ich würde auch wirklich
ganz fest das Herz legen,
mit der Theologie mit offenen Augen zu fliegen,
sich wirklich mit diesen Thematiken
auseinanderzusetzen,
diese Theoriesachen immer wieder zu studieren
und vor allem ganz wichtig in der Flugpraxis
euch immer wieder mit diesem Thema auseinanderzusetzen.
Wieso entstehen jetzt diese Wulchen?
Wieso habe ich jetzt den Wind?
Warum war das jetzt anders,
wie ich es erwartet habe?
Schaut euch auch die Meteoprognosen an,
die wir auch in einem anderen Teil anschauen,
wie man genau eine Meteoprognose macht.
Setzt euch damit auseinander,
redet mit eurem Fluglehrer, so viel ihr könnt.
Löchert den während eurer Ausbildung.
Fragt auch Flugkollegen,
tauscht euer Know-how aus,
fragt auch Locals,
wenn ihr mal jemanden mögt, der reisen möchte,
zum Beispiel auf eine Insel fliegen möchte.
Redet viel mit den Locals über die Wetterphänomene
und ihr werdet sehen, je mehr ihr hier lernt
und die Grundsätze anfangt zu verstehen,
uns vor allem in der Praxis
umsetzen könnt und seht,
es funktioniert immer mehr,
dass man die richtige Prognose getroffen hat,
dass man an den richtigen Ort angeflogen ist,
wo man die Thermik erwartet,
wo man die richtigen Entscheidungen gefällt hat,
desto mehr beginnt es auch Freude zu machen
und ich glaube gerade Meteorologie speziell
ist wirklich ein sehr motivierendes Thema
um von der Theorie dann auch in die Praxis umzusetzen
und viel Freude
und vor allem sicher fliegen können.
Genau.
Ich wünsche euch jetzt wirklich ganz schöne Flüge,
lernt hier gut, schaut rein,
schaut die Videos nochmal,
wir freuen uns auch auf eure Rückmeldungen
und wir wünschen euch ganz schöne Flüge
und gute Zeit.
Tschüss.